okay so this video is an old video right
and
i mean apparently some people have seen
it have uh i don't know if you've seen
it but i think it's absolutely worth
playing
so let me give you the rundown here this
is from 2014 i believe
and they're filming some sort of
spiritual retweet
retreat right where much like teddy hart
the people around them form a force
field oh okay
okay so by the way last night teddy hart
was talking about
he wants to have a match with all these
guys and then he started naming the
people he wants in his corner
and it was literally like half of the
wrestlers that ever existed in history
it was great
so let me just skip around a little bit
so this is three this is from a
documentary called three miles north of
malcolm
uh some of you might have seen it i
hadn't seen this and i know mike hasn't
seen this yet
uh from a few years ago and again these
are the people that believe in like
the chi and spiritual healing and
crystals and all that kind of [ __ ]
so this is them uh channeling their
spiritual energy
yes
[Music]
good good good now
you kind of get the p you kind of get
the picture of what this is about
uh they're channeling their energy so at
one point he picks this woman out from
the crowd
and says you don't have to touch can you
come magnus
and rebecca and he's going to show her
that just using the chi and spiritual
energy she could stop an attack
oh nice i mean except she can't but cool
mike
cool believe so if you stand here
you stand here and magnus and rebecca
you
prepare her and uh i don't know when i'm
gonna come so you have to prepare her
quick
so now the goal is she's going to build
up this energy
universal energy that's going to come
into her like from the chi and from the
nature
the tony soprano's mom over here right
so olivia soprano is she going to get
tackled by the guy who looks like jerry
lawler he's going to try to tackle her
but she's going to deflect it with the
internet
with the chi energy yeah check it out
it's pretty cool i don't know people
that actually do this
young jerry lawler yes so she's building
up she's building up
her energy here see here it is
it's great
[Music]
building it up building it up nice cargo
pants you can have a bunch of stuff in
her pockets
here comes the energy bring it in bring
it in bring it there it is
here we go here we go
here we go she's going super saiyan here
we go mike here we go
what happened to the g energy what
happened
that didn't look like it went according
to plan unless it just is
honestly if i ran after a tree like this
this would be my plan
just take money from stupid white people
and also tackle women
but get away with it like oh no i was
sure you failed to do the chi thing
you said that you know what's funny
about that wait to see the rest
[Music]
so now he worries about her for a second
right
and then falls
and he does this shaking thing which i
don't understand what's going on here
i guess the energy she got
[ __ ] breath is the funniest [ __ ] ever
your tail bones have met she got [ __ ]
up
now watch this
where were you guys where the [ __ ] were
you guys
it's their fault where were you guys
while i was tackling this lady where
were you guys out though
i did my job
so now look
see what they're doing with their hands
that's that reiki energy that's the
healing oh okay like mr miyagi yeah yeah
yeah no that's all fake
yes
now he's healing her look look he's
healing her
why how what if you just maybe not run
her over in the first place
healing we're getting healed now
we're getting healed you know what this
reminds me
this is like watching little kids play
yeah right
dude but like watching them do like girl
then i'll heal you my super powers and
you're like i guess
this is just bro white people were a
mistake
you know every time you [ __ ] come at
me with that [ __ ] like what about whites
why don't we deserve our own country and
our own culture no you don't
this is clear very this is clear
evidence that you don't
[Applause]
think he's healing of course you got it
here now
they go and they interview the other
people that saw it happen so now
i figure if i'm these people and i saw
this happening this is a crock of [ __ ] i
can't believe i fell for this right
that's what they would say
i
[Applause]
the [ __ ] am i watching ready to join us
in the circle
you ready to join us in the circle don't
be weak now
come on don't be a [ __ ] get up
i think she's really connected to like
deep power
being so close to she's connected to the
[ __ ] ground
she got leveled no no but listen why
she's connected listen let's listen
i think she's really connected to she's
like a deep power
being so close to death and being being
so close to death
she's touching she's like she's tired
you know touching on all these powers
and
on deep emotion you know when you say
you know she's connected you know i feel
that she has given up
that is my feeling it's her fault she
gave up she was not able to protect
herself
she gave up it's her it's her fault um
you ran at our at 30 miles an hour and
crashed into or with the force of vince
wilfork
i was saying it earlier but like if if
you hit tom brady like that you would be
kicked out of the league
yeah no seriously do that try to dump it
like that scary it's a lot of power
moving
but i it's really good you know i never
believed really you know
that he went four four you know
through you know and now i saw so i'm
really this is
really this is i really feel like you
know her
offensive line was not protecting her
properly then maybe they just don't see
her as a team leader do you know do you
want to defend
the thing is as you can see i'm not
faking it
so all you have to do if you're not
trying to knock me down you're just
defending yourself
you're seeing you'll see energy moving
and what you do
is it doesn't matter if people in the
way anything you see me moving as
soon as you see me move everything
everything you've got in there you push
it out can we do it we can do it
let's go i would love to join this thing
and then what i would do is i would just
sidestep the guy
and just let him [ __ ] [ __ ] fall
into the sand face first like at full
speed
and then be like there you go and then
somebody else volunteers for this these
people
like again like i don't i don't really
feel bad for her because she's the one
that paid probably seven
thousand dollars or some [ __ ]